nous sommes en train de réfléchir
également abaissé la cfe sur certains
secteurs d'activité avec une aide sur
les entreprises se basant sur nous ne
l'avons nous ne l'avons pas augmenté
nous avons simplement enlevé a
certainement pas 100 m vous voyez vous
avez même du mal vous parlez de
démocratie vous avez du mal à laisser
quelqu'un qui n'a pas la même opinion
que vous s'exprimer alors on est sur une
nouvelle jeunesse urd et que les dames
hier mais chut on locaux je l'avais
augmenté mais répondait alors je n'ai
pas actuellement est ce que vous avez
augmenté mais si vous me permettez de
répondre je n'ai pas l'intention de
tomber dans un
c'est qu'il y avait un certain nombre
d'exonérations qui favorisait les
grosses entreprises par rapport aux
punchers supprimés j'ai supprimé le taux
de ces feux je vous mets au défi le taux
de ces feuilles reste elle-même avant et
après et donc lavées vous avez les
supprimer des échelons et à madrid peut
laisser penser aux téléspectateurs celle
ci permet des exonérations qui
favorisait les grosses entreprises par
rapport aux petits voilà c'est dans
l'es6
nous avons été et on laisse finir et la
parole circule rage vous pouvez si vous
me laissez terminé je pourrais expliquer
hélas ce que nous allons faire nous
allons donner des exonérations de cf
grâce à une aide de l'état l'état
donnera une partie nous donnerons le
reste sur des secteurs qui ont été
particulièrement touchés je pense à
l'hôtellerie je pense à la restauration
voilà un certain nombre de secteurs qui
pourront bénéficier de ces baisses de
ces feux donc ce que nous avons fait
nous avons assuré la protection de nos
populations de notre économie pendant
ces crimes marie josé fleury je rappelle
vous êtes commerçant donc vous êtes
concerné vous connaissez bien la
question allez-y tout à fait sûr la
sieff d'ailleurs dès le départ dès le
mois de janvier on avait dénoncé en fait
cette orientation des bases locatives
qui chez les petits commerçants qui ont
des petits chiffres d'affaires ont fait
augmenter mais drastiquement la cfe on a
des augmentations et je veux dire ça y
est enfin
écoutez monsieur meslot on a eu des
augmentations 200 à 270 % chez la
plupart des commerçants
certains aujourd'hui se pose vous avez
tout non
messieurs mais ce sont les bases elle
dit ce sont les bases et actifs qui ont
augmenté milan ac 1161 tout adhérent
enlever les exonérations monde sait très
bien
si vous attendez attendez on va se
mettre d'accord ces bois qui anime ce
débat si vous parler ensemble on vous
coupe les migrants parce que de toute
façon c'est inaudible personne ne
comprend marie josé fleury à l'isi en
fait même si le set s'est faite à 29,5
c'est beaucoup trop
mulhouse est beaucoup plus bas que nous
montbéliard est beaucoup plus bas que
nous donc ça ne favorise pas les
installations marie josé fleury dans la
douleur sur cette question je vais vous
donner la parole samia jaber pour
conclure rapidement
du coup c'est une bonne chose que le
qu'il y ait une aide sur la cf
avec ce levier là pour les commerçants
aujourd'hui en difficulté elle est
vitale elle est vitale certains
commerces aujourd'hui sont très en
difficulté dans certains secteurs on le
voit notamment dans les grandes chaînes
au niveau national il ne faut pas se
leurrer ses difficultés nationales vont
redescendre en local et si effectivement
de ce côté là rien n'est fait d'autant
plus que monsieur meslot a en plus en
juin 2019
ajouter la taxe locale sur les anciennes
l'extérieur donc ça remis une nouvelle
taxe ça a remis une nouvelle taxe en
face a été voté en conseil municipal un
verre et une élue municipale elle va
pouvoir nous dire ce qu'il en est je ne
relancerait pas le débat nous avons déjà
eu ce débat au grand belfort au moment
où monsieur mais cela fait le choix
d'augmenter l'acf nous l'avions alertés
sur le fait que ça les impacts et
beaucoup plus de petites entreprises et
de commerce qui ne le pensait